Adults don't understand anymore what it means to be a nerd. Have you noticed this? Nerd, somehow, has become a badge of honor. You meet all kinds of people who say, proudly, that they were nerds in high school. It's like anybody who had anything that made them feel different now says that they were a nerd.
成年人不再理解“书呆子”意味着什么了。你们注意到了吗？不知何故，“书呆子”成了一种荣誉勋章。你会遇到各种各样的人，他们自豪地说自己在高中时是“书呆子”。就好像任何曾有某种特质让他们感到与众不同的人，现在都说自己是书呆子。
And that population-- the population that thinks that it was different-- that's like, everybody who went to high school. You know? People who were chubby, people who were in band, people who liked comic books, people who just didn't drink. I've met people who were actually popular, who actually had a social circle and boyfriends or girlfriends, who now claim they were nerds. That is just wrong.
而那群人——那些认为自己与众不同的人——几乎就是所有上过高中的人。你知道吗？胖乎乎的人、参加乐队的人、喜欢漫画书的人、甚至只是不喝酒的人。我遇到过那些曾经很受欢迎、有社交圈、有男/女朋友的人，现在也自称是书呆子。这简直是荒谬。
I believe that we have forgotten the sweaty, unsexy, cringe-inducing face of hard core nerdom.
我相信，我们已经遗忘了核心书呆子那种汗流浃背、缺乏吸引力、令人尴尬的本来面目。
I remember seeing a character on Beverly Hills 90210 wearing sports jackets to school. And I decided that that was a cool thing to do, and that I would do that. And it was the sort of thing that nobody quite understood. And everyone thought I was dressing up for something I had to go to after school. Everyone was sort of already tired of me at that point.
我记得在《飞越比弗利》里看到一个角色在学校穿运动夹克。我决定那很酷，我也要那样做。那是种没人完全理解的行为。大家还以为我穿成那样是为了放学后的什么活动。那时，大家都已经对我感到厌烦了。
That's David Iserson. When he was 13, David got a chance to change schools, leave the tiny school where everybody had known him since he was five, and start all over at a big public school where nobody knew him. And he had a very clear strategy for how he was going to create a glorious new life for himself.
那是大卫·伊瑟森（David Iserson）。13岁那年，大卫有机会转学，离开那个每个人从他五岁起就认识他的小学校，去一所没人认识他的大型公立学校重新开始。他有一个非常明确的策略，计划为自己创造一个辉煌的新生活。
I bore no illusions that I was going to be cool. So my only goal was to be anonymous. And I had some friends who were a year ahead of me in school. And that was their advice to me. Go in there. Do not say a word. Don't talk to anyone. Don't go up to anyone. Just sit in the back and stay anonymous. And that was my goal.
我没抱任何幻想自己会变酷。我唯一的目标就是默默无闻。我有几个高我一年的朋友，这是他们给我的建议：进去，别说一句话。别跟任何人说话。别去找任何人。就在后面坐着，保持隐形。这就是我的目标。
That was actually a pretty exciting prospect, of just being somebody that people barely noticed.
那其实是一个相当令人兴奋的前景，做一个几乎没人注意的人。
And for a few months it worked. But David didn't just want to be invisible. He also wanted to be an actor. I know. Complete contradiction. He was 13, remember.
几个月来，这招奏效了。但大卫不仅想隐形。他还想当演员。我知道，这完全是自相矛盾。记住，他才13岁。
He'd had a small part in Guys and Dolls at summer camp. He played a boy who talked to whales in this tiny community theater. And a couple times a week, his grandmother would drive him to auditions for TV commercials, though he never got cast in anything. Then, his dad came to him with a proposition.
他曾在夏令营的《红男绿女》里演过一个小角色。他在当地一个小剧团里扮演一个跟鲸鱼说话的男孩。每周有几次，他祖母会开车带他去参加电视广告试镜，尽管他从未被选中。后来，他父亲带给他一个提议。
His dad worked in the family business, this furniture store called Silvert's Furniture. And they'd just added a room full of desks, and beds, and shelving that was designed specifically for teenagers.
他父亲经营家族生意，那是一家名为“西尔弗家具”（Silvert's Furniture）的家具店。他们刚增加了一个房间，专门摆放为青少年设计的书桌、床和架子。
And for a while he had been doing the local television commercials for the store. So he said to me, "You want to be in commercials. I have a great idea. You should do the commercial for our store." I think he may have even presented it like, you know, I'm only so good at this, but you are a talented young actor. So I think you should promote our room of teen furniture.
他之前一直在为商店做当地的电视广告。所以他跟我说：“你不是想拍广告吗？我有个好主意。你应该为我们的店拍那个广告。”我想他当时表达得就像是：我不太擅长这个，但你是位有天赋的年轻演员。所以我认为你应该推广我们的青少年家具区。
He was flattered. He was thrilled. And they shot the ad. Which was a gas.
他受宠若惊，非常激动。于是他们拍摄了那则广告。这太好玩了。
So a few weeks later, my dad brings it home. And he's really, really excited about it. He talked to the guy, the director of it, and they both decided that this was a great commercial. And so he gathered the family into the family room. And he put on the VHS tape. And he started the commercial. And it didn't even have to run for a second before I just had this awful feeling in the pit of my stomach. Like, this was horrible.
几周后，我爸把它带回了家。他对此非常、非常兴奋。他跟那个导演聊过，他们都认为这是一则很棒的广告。于是他把家人聚在家庭活动室。他放了录像带。广告开始了。还没播出一秒钟，我的胃里就涌起一种可怕的感觉。天哪，这太糟糕了。
I'm sure all your parents know about the great selection of furniture for them here at Silvert's in Freehold. But they may not know about Silvert's huge selection of teen furniture. After all, we need something that suits us too.
我肯定你们的父母都知道这里，在弗里霍德的西尔弗家具店，有很棒的家具供选择。但他们可能不知道西尔弗还有海量的青少年家具。毕竟，我们也需要适合自己的东西。
Could you just describe what your hair cut looks like right here?
你能描述一下你当时的发型吗？
Well, I was sort of fashion-- I guess what could be described as a pompadour.
嗯，那是一种……我想可以被描述为蓬巴杜发型吧。
I would describe you more as, like-- and I don't want this to sound harsh. I mean this in a -- you look like Big Boy. You know Big Boy? From the hamburger chain? But with braces.
我更倾向于描述为——我不想说得太刺耳——我的意思是——你看上去像“大男孩”（Big Boy，汉堡连锁店的吉祥物）。你知道“大男孩”吗？那个汉堡连锁店的？但戴着牙套。
Yeah. I think that's probably accurate.
是的，我想那可能很准确。
For somebody who wanted to stay invisible, it is hard to imagine how this particular ad could have been worse for him. Everybody saw it. In the commercial David has an air of perfectly cheerful naivete.
对于一个想要保持隐形的人来说，很难想象这则广告怎么会对他造成更大的伤害。每个人都看到了。在广告里，大卫带着一种完美而快乐的天真神情。
In the first shot, he crosses the screen, careful to never stop facing the camera as he does this. Cut to him putting his school books onto a table. Cut to him lying on a bed on his stomach. In one shot he nods knowingly to the audience.
在第一个镜头里，他穿过屏幕，小心翼翼地一直面对摄像机。转场到他把课本放在桌子上。转场到他趴在床上。在一个镜头里，他心领神会地对着观众点头。
And furniture we feel comfortable just hanging out in. Oh yeah, Silvert's has sets for you girls, too. So take your mom and dad--
还有我们觉得可以舒服地呆着的家具。哦，对了，西尔弗也有适合你们女孩的套装。所以带上你们的爸爸妈妈——
To stop it there-- I mean, I think that's the line. That's the line that killed me. "We have sets for you girls, too." If anyone was to watch that commercial-- and when anyone did watch that commercial, who went to school with me, or anything like that-- that's the big laugh line. That's the thing bullies would say. You know, if I'm walking down the hall, and I hear someone say, "We have furniture for you girls, too," I know that I'm about to get shoved into a wall of lockers. It was almost like my warning.
别提那句了——我的意思是，那句台词。那句台词毁了我。“我们也有适合你们女孩的套装。”如果有谁看了那则广告——而当任何跟我同校的人或类似的人看那则广告时——那是个大笑点。那是霸凌者会说的话。你知道，如果我走在走廊里，听到有人说“我们也有适合你们女孩的家具”，我就知道我马上要被推到储物柜上了。那几乎成了我的预警。
That's the line that ended up following me, basically, all through my adolescence.
那句台词基本上贯穿了我整个青春期。
I have to say, when you say it, you give a little jaunty, over the shoulder, one thumb point.
我必须说，当你这么说的时候，你还带有一个轻快、越过肩膀、竖起大拇指的动作。
As I recall, that's how I was directed. And thank God they didn't use the take where I think I actually took a comb, and I combed it through my hair as I said it. Because if it could ever possibly be worse, it would have been worse by doing that.
我记得那是导演要求的。谢天谢地，他们没用我拿梳子边说边梳头的那一版。因为如果还能更糟，那动作就是更糟的原因。
And let's just describe what happens in the very last moment of the commercial.
咱们来描述一下广告最后时刻发生了什么。
So I'm saying my last little button on there. And my dad walks in--
我在说最后一句台词。然后我爸走了进来——
So take your mom and dad to Silvert's Furniture in downtown Freehold for all the furniture we need.
所以带上你的爸爸妈妈来弗里霍德市中心的西尔弗家具店买我们需要的所有家具。
Thanks, Dave. I couldn't have said it better myself.
谢了，戴夫。我自己都说不出这么好的台词。
I'm smiling. He puts his hand on my shoulder. I mean, it's like holding hands with your mom in the mall. And the "Thanks, Dave. I couldn't have said it better myself," was another line that got a lot of life out of it when I was walking through the halls of junior high school, and then later, high school.
我在微笑。他把手搭在我的肩膀上。我的意思是，这就像在商场里牵着妈妈的手一样。“谢了，戴夫。我自己都说不出这么好的台词。”这是另一句在我读初中和后来上高中时让我“备受折磨”的台词。
He says that a day did not go by for the next year without somebody mentioning the ad. Strangers, his friends, even adults. One teacher tried to get him to quote the commercial in a school play.
他说在接下来的一年里，没有哪一天不被人提起这则广告。陌生人、朋友、甚至成年人。有位老师甚至试图让他在学校演出中引用这则广告。
The ad ran a lot during New York Rangers hockey games. If you know anything about Rangers fans, this is maybe the least hospitable possible audience for an ad featuring a pompadour-wearing 13-year-old. These huge guys, men, would stop David and make him perform the ad for their girlfriends.
这则广告在纽约游骑兵队冰球比赛期间播了很多次。如果你了解游骑兵队的球迷，这可能是针对一个留着蓬巴杜发型的13岁少年最不友好的观众群。这些大块头，成年人，会拦住大卫，让他为他们的女朋友表演那个广告。
David always tried to protect himself by telling people that the stuff that he said in the commercial-- the way the he acted-- the store made him do all that. But, um, that wasn't true. He had written the whole thing himself.
大卫总是试图通过告诉别人广告里他说的话、他的表演方式——是商店强迫他做的——来保护自己。但，嗯，那不是真的。整篇文案都是他自己写的。
And when he watched the ad, it was actually a profound thing for him. He thought, this is how I seem to people? This is how it comes across when I talk?
当他重看这则广告时，那对他来说其实是一件深刻的事。他想，我在别人眼里就是这样吗？我说话时就是这种感觉吗？
My big fear was that they were all right, that everything they were making fun of was true. That that was me. Like I'd presented myself, and that was me.
我最大的恐惧是他们都是对的，他们嘲笑的一切都是真的。那就是我。我展示了自己，那就是我。
Do you think it was you? When you shot the commercial, you thought it was good. You wrote the commercial.
你觉得那就是你吗？拍摄广告时，你觉得它很好。你写了这则广告。
I mean, truthfully, I think it was me. I think it was me. I think as bad as it was, yeah, that was me.
我的意思是，说实话，我认为那就是我。我觉得那就是我。我想尽管它很糟，是的，那就是我。
And in a way, that's so much worse.
从某种程度上讲，那糟糕多了。
It's unbelievably worse. Because you can't escape that reputation even when you're alone.
那是难以置信的糟糕。因为即使你独处时，你也无法逃避那种名声。
But whatever it did to his personal life and to the way that he saw himself, the ad worked. It got people into the store. It ran for years. He was a successful spokesman, which is the subject of today's program. From Chicago Public Radio, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
但无论它对他的个人生活和自我认知造成了什么影响，广告确实奏效了。它吸引了人们进店。它播出了很多年。他是位成功的发言人，这也是今天节目的主题。来自芝加哥公共电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today on our show, The Spokesman. A program in three acts. We have a story where some people refuse to believe that a certain spokesman is an actual, real person. Adamantly refuse, to the point where it becomes a real public fight. That story from Jon Ronson, in Act One.
今天我们的节目主题是“发言人”。节目分三幕。第一幕，乔恩·罗森将带来一个故事：有些人拒绝相信某位发言人是个真正活着的人。他们坚决拒绝，甚至变成了一场真正的公开斗争。
In Act Two, we have the story of a teenage spokesman whose private life is the exact opposite, almost, of what he seems like in public. And in Act Three, a very unusual look inside the life of a presidential spokesman. Stay with us.
在第二幕，我们有一个少年发言人的故事，他的私生活几乎与他在公共场合的形象截然相反。而在第三幕，我们将深入了解一位总统发言人的生活。请继续收听。
Act One, What Part of "Bomb" Don't You Understand?" Jon Ronson has this story about somebody who becomes a spokesperson entirely by accident.
第一幕，“‘炸弹’这个词你哪里听不懂？”乔恩·罗森带来的故事，讲述了一个意外成为发言人的人。
A quick warning to people who are listening to our show on the internet, on our podcast or by streaming. For the internet version of this show, we have left in-- this is an experiment for us-- we have left in one curse word that occurs at a crucial moment in the story. Versus the broadcast version, where we bleeped it out. Here's Jon.
给在互联网上，通过我们的播客或流媒体收听节目的听众一个简短警告。对于本节目的网络版本，我们保留了一处——这是我们的一次实验——保留了一句在故事关键时刻出现的脏话。与我们将其消音的广播版本不同。下面是乔恩带来的内容。
One morning two years ago, Rachel North, who works in advertising, got on the Piccadilly Line tube at Finsbury Park, in north London.
两年前的一个早晨，从事广告工作的雷切尔·诺斯在北伦敦的芬斯伯里公园乘坐皮卡迪利线地铁。
It was the most rammed carriage I have ever been on in my entire life of using that line. And more and more people were pushing on and on. And I was sitting there thinking, this is ridiculous. And the train trundled off. And we'd been going for about 45 seconds, and then there was this explosion. I was about seven or eight feet away from it. So I felt this huge power smashing me to the floor.
那是我一生中乘坐过的最拥挤的车厢。人们还在不断地挤上来。我坐在那儿心想，这太荒谬了。火车缓缓开动。大约开了45秒后，发生了爆炸。我离爆炸点大约七八英尺远。所以我感觉到一股巨大的力量将我猛地摔向地面。
And everything went dark. And you could hear the brakes screaming, and it was racketing around. It was about being on an out of control fairground ride, but in the dark.
一切陷入黑暗。你可以听到刹车的尖叫声，车厢在剧烈摇晃。那感觉就像坐在失控的游乐场设施上，却是在黑暗中。
And it was very hot. You couldn't breathe at all. The air was just completely thick with smoke. And I was suddenly wet, completely wet. And I was on the floor. And there were people lying on top of me. And then the screaming started.
天气非常热。你根本无法呼吸。空气中完全充满了烟雾。我突然浑身湿透，完全湿透。我躺在地上。有人压在我身上。然后尖叫声开始了。
Three years earlier, Rachel had been violently attacked by a stranger in her home. In July, 2005, she wrote an article about the attack in Marie Claire magazine. That's what she was doing the moment the bomb exploded, standing on a packed tube train, reading the Marie Claire article about her violent attack. As she lay on the ground she thought, not again.
三年前，雷切尔在家中遭到一名陌生人的暴力袭击。2005年7月，她在《嘉人》杂志上写了一篇关于那次袭击的文章。就在炸弹爆炸的那一刻，她正在拥挤的地铁车厢里读着那篇关于自己受袭的文章。当她躺在地上时，她心想：不要再来一次。
We started to evacuate the train. And I was one of the last people to get off. And as I went to leave, I did a quick sweep around behind me. And I did see some of what had happened, yes. And that has stayed with me, because I still worry whether I should have stayed and tried to help people, even though it was really dark and all I could see was that there was some bent metal, there was people on the floor, there was-- I won't say what I saw, but it was pretty horrific.
我们开始疏散车厢。我是最后一批离开的人之一。当我离开时，我快速扫视了身后。我确实看到了一些发生了什么，是的。那一直留在我心里，因为我仍然担心我当时是否应该留下来尝试帮助别人，尽管当时非常黑暗，我能看到的只有扭曲的金属、躺在地上的受害者，还有……我不想说我看到了什么，但非常恐怖。
How many people died in your carriage?
你的车厢里有多少人遇难？
26 people died in my carriage. It should have been more, but because the carriage was so packed-- what happened was the people who were very close to the bomb got the full blast. And then the people who were about three, four yards away from the bomb got very bad lower limb injuries.
我的车厢里有26人遇难。本应有更多人的，但因为车厢太挤了——发生的情况是，离炸弹非常近的人承受了全部冲击力。而距离炸弹三、四码的人遭受了严重的下肢创伤。
There had been three simultaneous bomb explosions on London Underground trains around 9:00 AM and one more on a bus an hour later. 56 people were killed, including the four suicide bombers who were all from England, and one was a primary school teacher. 700 people were injured.
当时伦敦地铁同时发生了三起爆炸，一小时后又有一辆公交车发生爆炸。56人遇难，包括四名自杀式炸弹袭击者，他们都是英国人，其中一人还是小学教师。700人受伤。
Rachel had a bad gash full of glass on her wrist, which was so deep she could see her bone. But she was what paramedics call walking wounded. When she got home from the hospital a few hours later, she took a shower and tried to sleep. But she couldn't. So instead she got up and went online to her favorite web site, a large London community message board.
雷切尔的手腕上有一道布满玻璃碎片的深伤口，深到可以看到骨头。但她属于医护人员所说的“步行伤员”。几小时后她从医院回家，洗了个澡尝试睡觉。但她睡不着。于是她起床上网查看她最喜欢的网站，一个大型伦敦社区留言板。
There were hundreds of messages about the bombs already. But none had been written by someone who had actually been a passenger on a bombed train. She began posting.
上面已经有数百条关于爆炸的消息。但没有一条是真正的亲历乘客写的。她开始发帖。
"Thursday, 7th of July, one minute to 11. I was on a crowded train to work. It was 8:40 AM when I boarded the Grand Piccadilly Line train at Finsbury Park--"
“7月7日星期四，11点前一分钟。我当时在上班的拥挤火车上。早上8点40分，我在芬斯伯里公园登上了格兰德皮卡迪利线列车……”
She wrote and wrote, day after day. A flood of blog postings. The BBC discovered her blog and published it on their website. Her accounts of the July 7 bombings became one of the most read, and most beautifully written, on the internet.
她日复一日地写啊写。海量的博客文章。BBC发现了她的博客并将其发布在网站上。她关于7月7日爆炸案的叙述成为互联网上阅读量最高、文笔最优美的文章之一。
"Saturday, 9th of July. Yesterday was a weird day. Couldn't stop watching news. When I started hearing the bomb was in my carriage, I flipped. I started pacing about. I was alternately pounding with anger and adrenaline and having mini flashbacks, then feeling falling over tired. I drank several whiskeys. My sister came to visit--"
“7月9日星期六。昨天是奇怪的一天。无法停止观看新闻。当我开始听到炸弹就在我车厢里时，我崩溃了。我开始来回踱步。我交替感受着愤怒和肾上腺素的冲击，伴随着小型的闪回，然后感到疲惫不堪。我喝了几杯威士忌。我姐姐来看我……”
I didn't see it as putting myself into the public eye as a spokesperson at all. I just wrote about it. It was a way of disentangling all these horrible memories that were keeping me up at night. And by typing them down, it was like cleaning a wound. I was picking all the grit and the smoke out of my mind.
我根本没把自己当成什么代言人。我只是写下来。这是一种解开那些每晚让我失眠的可怕记忆的方式。通过敲击键盘，就像在清理伤口。我在清除脑海中所有的砂砾和烟尘。
Rachel started getting emails from other survivors who had seen her blog. These were people like her, who had walked away that day in a daze, and just tried to get on with their lives. But they discovered they were experiencing much the same post traumatic symptoms.
雷切尔开始收到其他幸存者的电子邮件，他们都看过她的博客。他们像她一样，那天在恍惚中逃生，试图继续生活。但他们发现自己经历了许多同样的创伤后应激症状。
There were people saying that they were unable to feel any joy in being alive. Every time they went to sleep, they would have nightmares. They would have nightmares of banging their hands against the glass of the train, battering away, trying to smash their way out of this train that was filled with smoke. And a lot of people thought they were going to burn to death. And they couldn't get out. There was no way of escaping. And they all thought they were literally going to die entombed.
有人说他们无法感受到活着哪怕一丝喜悦。每次入睡，他们都会做噩梦。他们梦见自己用手拍打火车的玻璃，疯狂地想要砸开这辆充满烟雾的车厢。许多人以为自己要被烧死了。他们出不去。没有任何逃生的办法。他们都以为自己会被活埋。
And none of us expected it. We were just on the way to work.
我们谁也没想到会这样。我们当时只是在去上班的路上。
Rachel organized for them all to meet in a pub together once a month. They formed a kind of unofficial support group and called themselves Kings Cross United. The media found out about them and thought it was a good story. So they needed a spokesman. Rachel had a background in advertising, and now she was quite a famous blogger. And she was able to hold it together in public. So she was the obvious candidate.
雷切尔组织他们每月在酒吧见一次面。他们成立了一个非官方的互助小组，自称“国王十字联合会”（Kings Cross United）。媒体发现了他们，认为这是一个好题材。于是他们需要一个发言人。雷切尔有广告背景，现在她是一位相当有名的博主。她能在公共场合保持镇定。所以她是显而易见的候选人。
She carried on writing her blog. And this is when it started getting a bit strange. People she didn't know began posting weird, cryptic comments she didn't quite understand on her site.
她继续写博客。就在这时事情开始变得有些奇怪。她不认识的人开始在她的网站上发布一些她不太理解的怪异、隐晦的评论。
You can install a thing that tells you where your visitors are coming from called Site Meter. I noticed a few weeks after installing that, I seemed to be getting an awful lot of hits from a particular website. So I went to look to the website. And I was interested to discover that somebody on that website had taken my original account of the bombs, and was claiming that it was actually a description of a power surge, which I found very strange, because a power surge doesn't rip people's limbs off and kill people.
你可以安装一个叫Site Meter的工具来告诉你访客来自哪里。安装几周后，我注意到我的流量似乎有很大一部分来自一个特定的网站。于是我去看了那个网站。令我感兴趣的是，网站上有人竟然拿着我最初对炸弹的描述，声称那实际上是对“电压波动”的描述，这让我觉得非常奇怪，因为电压波动不会把人的四肢撕碎并杀死他们。
There's a small but loud group of July 7 conspiracy theorists who believe that an accidental power surge had coursed through the London Underground that day, and that the British government wanted to cover up this corporate manslaughter by blaming it on Islamic suicide bombers.
有一小群但声音响亮的“7月7日阴谋论者”，他们相信那天伦敦地铁发生了偶然的电压波动，英国政府想通过将其归咎于伊斯兰自杀式炸弹袭击者来掩盖这起企业过失杀人。
On the site that Rachel found, a poster had quoted one of her original descriptions of her experience, where she writes about the electricity being cut out and the train descending into total darkness. The poster used her writing as evidence to support this power surge theory.
在雷切尔发现的网站上，一名发帖者引用了她对自己经历的原始描述之一，文中她写到电力中断，火车陷入完全黑暗。发帖者将她的文字用作支持这种“电压波动”理论的证据。
As Rachel read all of this stuff, she wondered how they'd account for the bus bombing. And then she found it. The conspiracy theorists maintained that the bus on Tavistock Square didn't really explode. It was actually a fake stunt using fancy pyrotechnics and stuntmen and actors.
当雷切尔读到这一切时，她想知道他们怎么解释公交车爆炸案。然后她找到了。阴谋论者坚称塔维斯托克广场的公交车并没有真正爆炸。那实际上是使用花哨的烟火效果和特技演员拍摄的假戏。
Which I thought was just obscene, given that, by that stage, I had met people who had lost loved ones on that bus. To call the people on the bus, who died, actors and stuntmen, was, I thought, quite abhorrent.
我觉得这简直是极其无耻，因为到那时为止，我已经遇到了在那辆公交车上失去亲人的人。称那些死在公交车上的人是演员和特技演员，我认为非常可恶。
And the people who were spreading these theories, had they brought you into it at this point?
而那些传播这些理论的人，当时把你牵扯进去了吗？
They were just quoting me, as if I had--
他们只是引用我，好像我……
Confirmed it.
证实了它。
And so Rachel felt uncontrollably compelled to do something unwise. She decided to jump into the fray, jump into the lives of the internet conspiracy theorists. She decided to get involved, and try and convince them that their theories weren't true.
于是，雷切尔感到一种无法遏制的冲动，要去做些不明智的事。她决定跳入浑水，跳入互联网阴谋论者的生活中。她决定介入，并尝试说服他们，他们的理论不是真的。
He was inviting comments on his website. So I dived in, and I read all his stuff. And then I came up for air. And then I left a very angry comment going, how dare you misquote me in this way. Power surges do not tear people's legs off. And then he responded by saying, you didn't even know the bomb was in your carriage. You keep changing your story. And basically had a go at me.
他在自己的网站上邀请评论。所以我跳了进去，读了他所有的内容。然后我透了口气。我留下了一条非常愤怒的评论：“你们竟敢这样歪曲引用我。电压波动不会把人的腿撕碎。”他回复说：“你甚至不知道炸弹就在你车厢里。你一直在改变你的故事。”基本上就是跟我杠上了。
And you started engaging with him a lot?
你开始和他们有大量互动吗？
I was furious with him. I just thought, oh, they don't realize. As soon as they actually talk to a real person, they'll realize it's a load of nonsense and they'll give up. I had no idea, at all then, about what these people were like.
我对他愤怒极了。我心想，哦，他们没意识到。只要他们真正跟一个活生生的人交谈，他们就会意识到这是一派胡言，然后就会放弃。当时我完全不知道这些人是什么样的。
But what comes through again and again is this lack of empathy. Complete lack of empathy. So they would, for example, cut and paste these most harrowing descriptions by emergency services officers of going into carriages and seeing buckled walls that were streaming with blood, and pieces of human flesh, and stepping over body parts. And stepping over the hole where the bomb had torn a crater in the floor.
但一遍又一遍展现出来的是这种缺乏同理心。完全缺乏同理心。例如，他们会剪切并粘贴紧急服务人员最令人揪心的描述：进入车厢，看到布满血迹的扭曲墙壁，人体残肢，跨过尸体部件。跨过炸弹在车厢地板上炸出的弹坑。
They'd post this. And you couldn't read it without actually wanting to weep. And then they would say, that you see. The hole there appears to be on the right-hand side. And that would be their comment.
他们会贴出这些。你看的时候不可能不感到想要流泪。然后他们会说：“你看，那里的洞似乎在右边。”这就是他们的评论。
They're just interested in the crater?
他们只对那个弹坑感兴趣？
Yeah, just weird.
是的，太怪异了。
Rachel believed what most people believe, that the July 7 attacks were the workers of Mohammed Sidique Khan and his three accomplices, and not a conspiracy involving actors and the British government. She told the conspiracy theorists that they were fantasists, and that it wasn't nice to find yourself a character in another person's paranoid fantasy, especially when you've just been blown up on the tube.
雷切尔相信大多数人所相信的，即7月7日袭击是穆罕默德·西迪克·汗及其三名同伙的所为，而不是涉及演员和英国政府的阴谋。她告诉阴谋论者他们是幻想家，在经历了地铁爆炸后，还要发现自己成了别人偏执幻想中的角色，这种感觉并不好。
But by engaging with them, Rachel herself became part of the conspiracy.
但通过与他们交涉，雷切尔自己也成了阴谋论的一部分。
They all started discussing me. And they formed the most bizarre theories about me. They decided that because I had this group that I'd set up, and that I had this blog that I'd set up, I was feeding the official story to the survivors. And I was somehow controlling them. And I was a government mouthpiece who'd been tasked with disseminating disinformation.
他们开始讨论我。他们对我形成了最怪异的理论。他们断定，因为我成立了这个小组，又建立了博客，我是在向幸存者传播官方故事。我在某种程度上控制了他们。我是一个政府喉舌，受命传播虚假信息。
And they became very suspicious of me. They formed this theory that I was some kind of counterintelligence professional or security services covert operative. Actually, some of them thought I didn't even exist. They thought I was a team of men who were tasked with creating this Rachel from north London persona, and maintaining it as a means of what they called psy-ops, you know, psychological operations to control the population of the UK.
他们开始对我非常怀疑。他们形成了一种理论，认为我是某种反情报专业人员或安全部门的秘密特工。实际上，有些人甚至认为我根本不存在。他们认为我是由一群人组成的团队，受命创建这个“北伦敦雷切尔”的人设，并维持它，作为他们所谓的“心理战”（psy-ops）手段，用来控制英国民众。
I've just found what somebody's written about you here.
我刚发现有人在这儿写了关于你的东西。
"Rachel--" and then in  brackets "Rachel Schmachel" as if to imply that your name's not really Rachel. "It's your tone of voice that is the give away. You also seem to think that having been involved directly in the events of the day-- were you really-- confers upon you some special status and insight." That's annoying.
“雷切尔——”然后括号里写着“雷切尔·什雷切尔”（Rachel Schmachel），似乎暗示你的名字并不是真的雷切尔。“你的语气出卖了你。你也似乎认为，亲身参与了当天的事件——你真的参与了吗？——就赋予了你特殊的地位和洞察力。”这太烦人了。
Oh, that wasn't even the worst of it. There was a lot worse than that. [INTERPOSING VOICES] "--people disinformation shill all [BLEEP] and no evidence. It should be clear from Rachel's dis-info tactics she's part of the same lying media and police who set up this scam. Bet it ain't even female."
哦，那还不是最糟的。还有比这糟糕得多的。[交叉谈话] “……传播虚假信息的走狗，纯属[脏话]而且没有证据。从雷切尔的虚假信息策略来看，她显然是造成这场骗局的谎言媒体和警察的一部分。敢打赌她甚至不是女性。”
They're referring to you as it. They're saying, "Bet it ain't even female." You wrote this at the bottom of all this stuff about you, which just seems really sad. You wrote, "I do not work for the government. I'm a normal person. I have a normal job in a normal office, and I'm getting sick of this. I'm requesting politely that you drop this and stop making accusations which are not true. It is completely out of order, frankly. Please stop."
他们用“它”来指代你。他们说：“敢打赌它甚至不是女性。”你在这一切关于你的东西下方写道，这看起来真让人难过。你写道：“我不为政府工作。我是一个普通人。我在一个普通的办公室里有一份普通的工作，我受够了。我礼貌地请求你们放弃这个，停止做出不真实的指控。说实话，这完全不妥。请停止。”
What they were doing to Rachel was incredibly insulting. She'd almost been killed. She runs a support group for people who were almost killed. And now she was getting death threats from the conspiracy theorists. They contacted her parents, who found the whole thing frightening and confusing. So Rachel decided to confront them, face to face.
他们对雷切尔所做的事情极其侮辱。她差点就死了。她为那些差点死去的人经营一个互助小组。现在她却收到了阴谋论者的死亡威胁。他们联系了她的父母，她的父母觉得这一切既恐怖又令人困惑。所以雷切尔决定与他们面对面交锋。
She went to a meeting where the conspiracy theorists spokesman, David Shayler, was speaking. The floor was opened up for Q and A's. And Rachel raised her hand and argued against the idea that July 7 was an inside job.
她去参加了一场会议，阴谋论者的发言人戴维·谢勒正在发言。会议开放了问答环节。雷切尔举手反驳了7月7日是内部阴谋的观点。
Then everybody started shouting. And so I raised my voice to be heard over them shouting. They shouted, I shouted. They make it sound like I got up from the floor, marched onto the stage and started declaiming away. That's not what happened. The whole room erupted in shouting.
然后大家都开始大喊大叫。所以我提高了嗓门以盖过他们的叫喊。他们喊，我也喊。他们说得好像是我从地上站起来，走上舞台开始滔滔不绝。事实并非如此。整个房间陷入了叫喊声中。
Let me talk about Rachel North being an excellent composite MI5 person.
咱们来聊聊雷切尔·诺斯作为一名完美的军情五处（MI5）合成人物。
This is David Shayler, who was on stage that night. He's a former MI5 officer who's jumped sides to become a hero to the conspiracy theorists. He says it's not so crazy to believe that Rachel is the creation of a team of agents from his old organization.
这就是当晚在台上的戴维·谢勒。他曾是军情五处官员，后来倒戈，成为阴谋论者眼中的英雄。他说，认为雷切尔是其老东家特工团队的创造物，并不是那么疯狂。
Honestly, I think you should present the evidence to people of why people are saying that.
老实说，我认为你应该向人们展示证据，说明为什么人们会那样说。
OK. Why do you think people are saying that?
好的。你觉得为什么人们会那样说？
They're saying it was so because Rachel North won't have a dispassionate briefing about 7/7 in which somebody talks her through the evidence. Anybody who's not prepared to engage with evidence, their opinion is not worth anything.
他们那样说是因为雷切尔·诺斯不愿进行一场冷静的关于7/7的简报，让别人带她了解证据。任何不准备面对证据的人，他们的观点一文不值。
So do you think there's a chance that Rachel North is a composite of MI5 agents?
所以你认为雷切尔·诺斯有可能是军情五处的合成人物吗？
Well, I don't know. I'm sorry. I haven't seen the full evidence on that. All I know is--
嗯，我不知道。抱歉。我没看到关于那点的全面证据。我所知道的是——
But do you think it's a possibility?
但你认为这是一种可能性吗？
Well, anything is a possibility, isn't it? Of course anything's a possibility. But I don't think we should dismiss these things, the idea that the intelligence services would create a composite figure. I don't think we should dismiss that idea, because that's exactly the kind of thing they would do.
嗯，一切皆有可能，不是吗？当然一切皆有可能。但我不认为我们应该忽视这些事情，认为情报部门会创造一个合成人物的想法。我不认为我们应该忽视这个想法，因为那正是他们会做的那种事。
But you've met her?
但你见过她？
I've met her. But what I'm trying to say is that Rachel North can exist as a figure. But it doesn't mean necessarily there's not five people behind her, posting in her name on the internet to get stuff out there. Once you've got a name, anybody could be posting that stuff on the internet, can't we?
我见过她。但我想说的是，雷切尔·诺斯可以作为一个人物存在。但这并不一定意味着她背后没有五个人，以她的名义在互联网上发帖来散布东西。一旦有了名气，任何人都可以在网上发那些东西，不是吗？
Well I think you seem to think that the only reason why Rachel might be a group of men working for MI5 is because she doesn't want to sit down and engage with the conspiracy theorists.
嗯，我认为你似乎认为雷切尔可能是军情五处雇佣的一群男人，唯一的原因是她不想坐下来跟阴谋论者交涉。
No, I'm not. It's to do with her prestigious posting on the internet. And again, I think you should look at the evidence there about how many posts she was doing at one point.
不，不是。这跟她在网上的那些高调的发帖有关。再次说明，我认为你应该看看关于她在某个阶段发帖数量的证据。
She was posting a lot.
她当时发帖确实很多。
Because I think other people have looked at this in the movement, and come to the opposite conclusion, that there were far too many posts to come from one person.
因为我认为运动中的其他人也研究过这一点，并得出了相反的结论：发帖量太多了，不可能来自一个人。
You know what bloggers are like. They just write, and write, and write. I don't understand why, because they're not getting paid.
你知道博主是什么样的。他们就是写啊，写啊，写啊。我不明白为什么，因为他们又没钱拿。
I've crossed paths with the conspiracy theorists myself. I've spoken out against their irrational thoughts. And in retaliation they've set up a discussion thread called "Jon Ronson, shill or stupid?" A shill is a paid stooge.
我自己也曾与阴谋论者狭路相逢。我公开发言反对他们非理性的思想。作为报复，他们开设了一个名为“乔恩·罗森，是走狗还是白痴？”的讨论帖。“走狗”是指受雇的傀儡。
My experience with them is nothing compared to the abuse and the hate that Rachel incurred. But still, I've had terrible online fights with them. You're probably thinking it's nuts to engage with them. And you'd be right. It is nuts. It does nothing but bad. But when you're inside the bubble, sitting alone in your room, staring at the internet, sometimes it's really hard to control yourself and do the sensible thing.
我跟他们的经历与雷切尔遭受的辱骂和仇恨相比不算什么。但即便如此，我还是跟他们进行过可怕的网络斗争。你可能觉得跟他们交涉简直疯了。你是对的。确实疯了。这只会造成恶果。但当你身处泡沫中，独自坐在房间里，盯着互联网时，有时真的很难控制自己去理智行事。
Do you regret jumping in and getting involved with them?
你后悔跳进去介入他们了吗？
I think morally it was the right thing to do. I think from a personal point of view, I could do without the hate mail. I could do-- I've had death threats. I feel upset that my family were contacted.
从道德上讲，我认为这是正确的做法。从个人角度看，我本可以不需要那些仇恨邮件。我本可以——我收到过死亡威胁。我的家人被联系过，这让我感到难过。
When somebody who was actually there, at the moment of the explosion-- rather than somebody who sits at home on the internet and theorizes-- comes and confronts the theorists, why do the conspiracy theorists get so angry and so personal?
当一个真正身处现场、在爆炸那一刻的人——而不是一个坐在家里在互联网上瞎想的人——去面对那些理论家时，为什么阴谋论者会变得如此愤怒和人身攻击？
Well, I think again, you're trying to make this to be the case. But I have to say when Rachel North did come to one of our meetings, I thought her behavior showed signs of mental illness.
嗯，我觉得你又在强加观点了。但我不得不说，当雷切尔·诺斯确实来到我们的会议时，我认为她的行为表现出了精神疾病的迹象。
You think Rachel is mentally ill?
你觉得雷切尔有精神病？
No, I'm saying that the behavior I saw of her then-- I don't know her particularly well-- showed signs of mental illness.
不，我是说我当时看到她的行为——我跟她不算太熟——表现出了精神疾病的迹象。
What did she do that was mentally ill-ish?
她做了什么看起来像精神病的事？
It was the degree with which she attacked me for happening to say this thing about precisely the same stations. It was a fact that once she said it, she stood up, came running towards me and started shouting at me. There was a madness about this. And I would invite you to actually interview anybody else who was there, because they will say the same thing.
是因为她攻击我的程度，仅仅因为我恰巧说了关于同一地点的一些事情。事实上，一旦她说了那些话，她就站起来，朝我冲过来，开始对我大喊大叫。这其中有一种疯狂。我建议你去采访任何当时在场的人，因为他们会说同样的事情。
But that's because Rachel thinks it's nonsense--
但那是因为雷切尔觉得那是胡说八道——
But how does she know until she's seen the evidence? I'm getting the same sort of vibe off you here, Jon. You think it's nonsense. You haven't seen the evidence, you see? This is the problem we're in, because a viewpoint arrived at without evidence is prejudiced. And to say that Muslims carried out 9/11, those three guys from Leeds, and one from Aylsebury, without evidence--
但在看到证据之前她怎么知道？乔恩，你身上也有一种类似的感觉。你觉得那是胡说八道。你还没看到证据，你明白吗？这就是我们所处的问题，因为在没有证据的情况下得出的观点就是偏见。说穆斯林制造了9/11，那三个来自利兹的人，还有一个来自艾尔斯伯里的，在没有证据的情况下——
7/7, you mean?
你是说7/7吧？
Sorry, 7/7. Sorry, 7/7. The four guys that supposedly carried out 7/7, the evidence is simply not there to say it.
抱歉，7/7。抱歉，7/7。那四个据称实施了7/7的人，说他们做了这件事的证据根本不存在——
What about--
那——
To say they did it--
说他们做了这件事——
What about the video? Was that set up?
那视频呢？那是伪造的吗？
Is racist, Jon. It's racist. You're being racist against Muslims, if you think those three guys carried out that attack on the evidence there.
是种族主义，乔恩。那是种族主义。如果你认为那三个人在证据不足的情况下实施了那次袭击，你就是在对穆斯林进行种族歧视。
Oh, fuck off.
噢，滚蛋。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's what I uncontrollably feel as if I should say to you, though. For so many reasons, David.
但戴维，因为太多的原因，这确实是我无法控制地想对你说的话。
-- include the recording of that in the actual interview, please, because-- or could I have a recording of that to play to people now? Because I don't think Jon here is actually being an objective interviewer at all. This is very, very personal, Jon. No one seems to appreciate that I've come to talk to you today. There has been enormous interest in 9/11 Truth Movement.
——请把那段录音包含在实际采访中，因为——或者我能有一份录音现在放给人们听吗？因为我觉得乔恩你在这里根本不是一个客观的采访者。这非常、非常私人，乔恩。似乎没人意识到我今天来是跟你谈话的。人们对“9/11真相运动”有巨大的兴趣。
I'll be absolutely honest with you that certain people have said to me, before I came here, you should be very careful of this man. He may be a shill, and so on. I said, I don't think that. I'm going to go and talk to the man and find out what he's all about.
我可以诚实地告诉你，在来这里之前，有些人对我说：“你要非常小心这个人。他可能是一个走狗，等等。”我说，我不这么认为。我要去跟这个人谈谈，了解他到底是什么人。
And now that you've met me, do you think they're right and that I am a shill?
现在你见过我了，你觉得他们是对的，我是一个走狗吗？
No, I don't. I don't think you're a shill at all. No.
不，我不觉得。我觉得你根本不是走狗。不。
So will you tell them that I'm not a shill?
所以你会告诉他们我不是走狗吗？
Of course I will. In fact, that's a conclusion I've-- Well let me explain. What I've read about you, and what I understand of this interview here, Jon, I honestly can say, the honest opinion from my heart, I don't think you're a shill.
我当然会。事实上，这是一个我得出的结论——嗯，让我解释一下。乔恩，关于你的阅读，以及我对这次采访的理解，我真的可以诚实地说，从内心深处，我不觉得你是走狗。
I've got to admit, the whole thing began because I inadvertently typed my name into Google, and accidentally pressed search. And I found a website-- or I found a discussion that was called "Jon Ronson, shill or stupid?"
我得承认，整件事的开始是因为我无意中在谷歌输入了自己的名字，不小心按了搜索。然后我发现了一个网站——或者我发现了一个讨论帖，叫“乔恩·罗森，是走狗还是白痴？”
Well as I said, I don't think you're a shill. But I think we're entitled to say anybody--
好吧，如我所说，我不觉得你是走狗。但我认为我们有权说任何人——
You think I'm stupid?
你觉得我是白痴？
No, no, no. But if you don't want to see the evidence about 9/11, I've got to say that's not a sign of intellect.
不，不，不。但如果你不想看关于9/11的证据，我不得不说那不是智力的体现。
OK. When you go back and tell them, will you tell them that I'm not a shill, but also that I'm not stupid?
好的。当你回去告诉他们时，你会告诉他们我不是走狗，但也请告诉他们我不是白痴？
OK.
好的。
Because it's a bit insulting.
因为那有点侮辱人。
Jon, I get the same thing myself. So I'm entirely sympathetic to you. But I have to say with proviso, again, that if you don't take the briefing, I will have to say that's a sign of--
乔恩，我也有同样的经历。所以我完全同情你。但我必须附带一个前提：再次说明，如果你不接受简报，我不得不说那是……的迹象。
Shilldom?
“走狗行为”？
No, no, no--
不，不，不——
Stupidity?
“愚蠢”？
No. Ignorance.
不。无知。
Ignorance. OK. Well he's not a shill, he's not stupid, but he's ignorant. I can live with that. That I can live with.
无知。好吧。他不是走狗，他不是白痴，但他无知。这个我能接受。这个我可以接受。
The conspiracy theorists insist that if I, or Rachel, or anyone else sits down and takes their briefing, we'll agree with them by the end. I think they truly can't imagine it working out any other way. I guess it's pejorative, but the reason why I don't want to take the briefing is because I think the experience would suck the very soul out of my body through my ears.
阴谋论者坚持认为，如果我、或雷切尔、或任何其他人坐下来听取他们的简报，我们最终会同意他们的看法。我认为他们真的无法想象还有其他结局。我想这带有贬义，但我之所以不想听简报，是因为我认为那次经历会通过我的耳朵，吸干我身体里的灵魂。
When they hear this, they're still not going to believe that you exist, some of them, especially because I'm interviewing you, because they see me as part of the cabal.
当他们听到这些时，他们中的一些人仍然不会相信你的存在，特别是当我采访你的时候，因为他们把我视为阴谋集团的一部分。
I've given up trying to change their minds now. I know I exist. All the people on the train who've met me know I exist. I got off the train covered in blood, and smoke, and soot, with glass in my hair, and metal sticking out of my wrist bone. I went and gave a statement to the police. I was photographed. I was stitched up in a hospital. I can produce dozens of witnesses that I was there, that I am who I am. And if some people choose not to believe that, then I pity them really.
我现在已经放弃改变他们的想法了。我知道我存在。车上所有见过我的人都知道我存在。我满身鲜血、烟雾和煤灰地下了火车，头发里全是玻璃，手腕骨头插着金属。我去向警察做了陈述。我被拍照了。我在医院缝了针。我可以出示几十个证人证明我在现场，证明我就是我。如果有些人选择不相信，那我就真的怜悯他们了。
Jon Ronson, who did that story, is the author of a book about conspiracy theorists called Them . A version of this story also appeared on his BBC Radio 4 series, John Ronson On.
乔恩·罗森，制作了那个故事的人，是关于阴谋论者的书《他们》的作者。这个故事的一个版本也出现在他的BBC电台第四台系列节目《乔恩·罗森论》中。
Coming up, I was a teenage spokesman. Not me, actually, the kid in the story. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
即将到来，我曾是一位少年发言人。其实不是我，是故事里的那个孩子。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共电台和国际公共电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show The Spokesman. Stories about what it can be like to be the spokesman.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种不同类型的相关故事。今天的节目是“发言人”。关于作为发言人是什么样的故事。
We've arrived at act two of our program, Act Two, Mr. Successful.
我们来到了节目的第二幕，“第二幕，成功先生”。
OK. Anybody's who's ever been to a wedding knows that not everybody can stand up in front of a roomful of people and just talk. Well, Anthony Pico discovered by accident, at 15-years-old, that he has a gift for doing that. He's 18 now. And he has become so well-known as a public speaker on the subject of foster care, which he knows well, that he was appointed to the blue ribbon commission that's now aiming to reform the largest foster care system in the country, the one in California, Anthony's home state.
好的。参加过婚礼的人都知道，并不是每个人都能站在满屋子人面前随意讲话。安东尼·皮科在15岁时偶然发现他有这方面的天赋。他现在18岁了。他作为寄养体系的主题公众演讲者已经变得非常出名，他非常了解这个话题，以至于被任命为蓝带委员会成员，旨在改革该国最大的寄养体系，也就是在安东尼的家乡加利福尼亚。
In addition, Anthony still speaks to judges and legislators all over the state and all over the country, to different groups, sometimes every week. But it's gotten complicated. Douglas McGray tells the story.
此外，安东尼仍然在全州和全国为法官和立法者演讲，面向不同的群体，有时每周都有。但事情变得复杂了。道格拉斯·麦格雷（Douglas McGray）讲述了这个故事。
Anthony is at a hotel near San Francisco Airport. He knows the room. Not this one, exactly, but dozens just like it. The long, windowless walls, the bad carpeting, the government officials, social workers, and nonprofit types sitting in quiet rows, as his host wraps up a long interaction.
安东尼在旧金山机场附近的一家酒店。他熟悉这个房间。不一定是这一间，但类似的有几十间。长长的、没有窗户的墙壁，糟糕的地毯，政府官员、社会工作者和非营利组织人士坐在安静的排椅上，主持人正在结束一场冗长的互动。
And I just want to let you all know you're in for a real treat. I've seen Anthony speak several times. He's a wonderful, wonderful, powerful advocate. Welcome Anthony Pico.
我只想让你们都知道，你们有福了。我见过安东尼演讲好几次了。他是一位出色、强大、有力的倡导者。欢迎安东尼·皮科。
Anthony walks toward the mic. I know what he's thinking right now, because I asked him.
安东尼走向麦克风。我知道他现在在想什么，因为我问过他。
I look down at the lectern. Get a sense for my space, how much I need to project, all this other stuff. I usually take a slight pause, look around.
我低头看讲台。感受一下我的空间，我需要投射多少声音，以及所有这些其他的事情。我通常会稍微停顿一下，四处看看。
So again, my name is Anthony Pico.
所以，再说一次，我叫安东尼·皮科。
Anthony is a steady presence up there, eyes calm and appraising. He doesn't shrink, doesn't hesitate. He just lays out his life.
安东尼在那里是一个稳定的存在，眼神冷静而审慎。他不退缩，不迟疑。他只是平铺直叙他的生活。
Well, I grew up in the foster care system, was born into it. Adopted at 12 by a relative. That person died when I was 14. And I re-entered the foster care system with another relative, the person who died last year. I've been within the mental health system since the age of 11 and had enough therapists that I believe I have my own PhD.
嗯，我在寄养体系中长大，一出生就在里面。12岁时被亲戚收养。那个人在我14岁时去世了。我又回到了另一个亲戚的寄养体系中，也就是去年去世的那个人。我从11岁起就一直在心理健康系统中，看过的治疗师多到我认为我可以拿自己的博士学位了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Most kids in foster care couldn't stand up there, talk for an hour with a half page of notes, and own the room the way Anthony does. Most of them are struggling just to hold their lives together. University of Chicago researchers did a massive survey of teens leaving the foster care system at 18. Within a year, nearly 70% had dropped out of high school. Half had lost their health insurance. Almost half the girls had gotten pregnant. One in five kids had spent a night in jail. And 15% had been homeless. What saved Anthony is public speaking. It came easily to him. He has always been a talker.
大多数寄养儿童无法站在那里，拿着半页笔记演讲一个小时，并像安东尼那样掌控全场。他们中的大多数人甚至在努力维持生计方面就很挣扎。芝加哥大学的研究人员对18岁离开寄养体系的青少年进行了一项大规模调查。一年内，近70%的人高中辍学。一半人失去了医疗保险。近一半的女孩怀孕了。五分之一的孩子曾入狱。15%的人曾无家可归。拯救安东尼的是公开演讲。这对他来说很容易。他一直是个健谈的人。
Yeah, I'd start conversations with anyone. It wasn't hard for me to break the ice. I was this little goth fat kid who would start conversations with people.
是的，我会跟任何人开始谈话。打破僵局对我来说并不难。我就是那个小哥特胖男孩，会跟人搭讪。
And so then how is it different now?
那现在有什么不同呢？
I'm this tall, fat, politician kid who starts conversations with people.
我是那个高大的、胖乎乎的、政客范儿的男孩，开始跟人谈话。
Anthony has the kind of life story you'd expect from a kid in foster care. Born crack-addicted to a mother who disappeared from the hospital just after she gave birth. Never knew his father. Relatives have mostly abused or ignored him. By 15, he was an angry, withdrawn kid. He weighed almost 300 pounds. He hated school, hated his life, thought about killing himself.
安东尼有着你期望寄养儿童拥有的那种生活经历。出生时就是瘾君子，母亲在他出生后不久就从医院消失了。从没见过父亲。亲戚大多虐待或忽视他。到15岁时，他是一个愤怒、退缩的孩子。他体重近300磅。他讨厌学校，讨厌他的生活，想过自杀。
Then he started giving speeches, and everything changed. Suddenly foster care wasn't just something happening to him. It was knowledge, knowledge that other people wanted, especially from a teenager who could speak fluent grown-up and who knows how the bureaucracy works and doesn't work.
然后他开始演讲，一切都变了。突然间，寄养不再仅仅是发生在他身上的事情。它成了知识，别人想要的知识，特别是来自一个能说流利的大人语言，并且知道官僚体系如何运作——以及如何失效——的青少年。
How many people have had another agency call them and say, yeah, I have this youth and I really think they're more under what your service provision is. And we can't really help them right now. So go ahead, and if you could take this youth, or this case, or this stack of papers, that'd be great. How many of you have had that? That's ridiculous to me. And I'm 18. I'm not supposed to know what ridiculous is yet.
有多少人收到过其他机构的电话，说：“是啊，我这儿有个青年，我真觉得他们更符合你们的服务提供范畴。我们现在实在帮不了他们。所以没关系，如果你能接手这个青年，或者这个案件，或者这堆文件，那就太好了。”你们有多少人遇到过这种情况？这对我来说太荒谬了。而我才18岁。我还不到应该知道什么是荒谬的年纪。
People in my classes didn't like me because I would always talk about how bad my life was. I would say, well, I don't have a dad. This and that, I'm worthless, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Well, when I started doing public speaking, it became-- not necessarily a badge of honor, but almost like a purple heart.
我班上的人不喜欢我，因为我总是谈论我的生活有多糟糕。我会说，嗯，我没有爸爸。这个那个，我一文不值，巴拉巴拉。嗯，当我开始进行公开演讲时，它变得——不一定是荣誉勋章，但更像是一枚紫心勋章。
It's the quarterly meeting of California's blue ribbon commission on foster care. Big shots in the state legislature, the courts, foundations, and the University of California have gathered for a couple days in a hotel near LA. They just finished dinner-- white table cloths, steaks, it was a  nice spread. Now everyone's milling around, schmoozing, networking. Anthony too.
这是加州寄养问题蓝带委员会的季度会议。州立法机构、法院、基金会和加州大学的大人物们在洛杉矶附近的一家酒店聚集了几天。他们刚吃完晚餐——白桌布，牛排，排场很不错。现在大家都在四处走动，闲聊，建立人脉。安东尼也是。
He's always angling for new speaking gigs.
他总是在争取新的演讲机会。
So Ken, when are you going to take me up to [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
所以肯，你什么时候带我去……？
You are welcome anytime.
你随时欢迎。
He is especially interested in tonight's guest speaker, an influential judge from Utah. Anthony has two half-siblings in Utah he wants to contact, but they've been adopted and their file is sealed. He wants the judge's help finding them. They end up talking for more than an hour. Anthony keeps up easily, even when the jargon and the acronyms start to span several complicated, overlapping bureaucracies, like the Bureau of Indian Affairs, BIA. Anthony and his siblings are Native American.
他特别对今晚的演讲嘉宾感兴趣，一位来自犹他的有影响力的法官。安东尼在犹他州有两个同父异母或同母异父的兄弟姐妹，他想联系他们，但他们被收养了，档案被封存了。他想要法官帮忙找到他们。他们最终交谈了一个多小时。安东尼接话很轻松，即使当术语和缩略语开始涵盖几个复杂的、重叠的官僚机构时，比如印第安事务局（BIA）。安东尼和他的兄弟姐妹是美国原住民。
It probably wouldn't be that hard to just go through BIA and see if they have them under their roll too. Because wouldn't BIA have a list of all enrolled members of every--
直接通过BIA看看他们是否也在他们的名册里，可能并不难。因为BIA不是应该有一份所有注册成员的名单吗？
I don't think they do. Because each of them determines their own eligibility for membership.
我觉得他们没有。因为他们每个人都决定自己成员资格的资格。
This is what Anthony has learned in three years of public speaking, how to work the system and his connections to get what he needs. In the end, the judge agrees to help him. Later, he tells me about a time he transferred schools and got stuck halfway. The new school wouldn't let him in. Most foster kids would have stayed home for weeks, maybe longer. And they do. This sort of thing happens all the time.
这就是安东尼在三年的公开演讲中学到的，如何运作系统和利用人脉来得到他需要的。最后，法官同意帮助他。后来，他告诉我他有一次转学并被卡在中间的情况。新学校不让他进。大多数寄养孩子会呆在家里几周，甚至更久。他们确实会那样。这种事经常发生。
They kept me out of school because I didn't have the right papers. Well, there's a law that was passed about a year and a half before I tried to go into that school that said you can not keep a foster youth out of school for more than three days, regardless of if they have their paperwork, or uniform, or anything like that. You have to keep them in school.
他们不让我上学，因为我没有合适的证件。嗯，在我尝试进入那所学校前大约一年半通过了一项法律，说你不能把一个寄养青年挡在学校门外超过三天，不管他们是否有证件、制服或任何类似的东西。你必须让他们上学。
And I emailed them after about a week saying, you are out of compliance with AB 490. If you do not enroll me as soon as possible, I will call my lawyer and the state ombudsperson. And I forwarded it to the school district, my placement office, my lawyer, and the foster care liaison to the district.
大约一周后，我给他们发了邮件，说：你们违反了AB 490法案。如果你不尽快让我入学，我会打电话给我的律师和州监察员。我还把它转发给了学区、我的安置办公室、我的律师以及该区的寄养联络员。
It almost sounds like you're your own pushy parent here.
听起来你就像是你自己的那种强硬的父母。
Yeah. Pretty much. I will be the person whose, like, I don't get a [BLEEP] what you say. I'm going to raise hell.
是的。差不多吧。我就是那种——我才不管你说什么。我要闹得天翻地覆。
Anythony's gotten good at a lot of things most kids leave to their parents, like finances. During a break, I give him a ride to a cash machine so he can make a deposit. Savings are a huge problem for most kids leaving foster care. But Anthony's banked $10,000, working close to full time at a movie theater.
安东尼在许多大多数孩子留给父母的事情上变得很擅长，比如理财。休息期间，我开车带他去取款机存钱。储蓄对大多数离开寄养体系的孩子来说是个大问题。但安东尼存了1万美元，他在电影院工作，几乎是全职。
Alone in his hotel room, Anthony unpacks. He's been on the road all week. He came to LA straight from another speaking appearance outside San Diego. He pulls an armful of conference swag out of his wheeled suitcase. A windbreaker. A travel thermos. A squishy stress ball. He unfolds four or five dress shirts, hangs them in the closet. Then he stops, pushes everything else to the floor, and plops in an overstuffed chair by the window.
在酒店房间里，安东尼独自拆开行李。他已经在路上跑了一整周了。他是从圣地亚哥外面的另一个演讲现场直接来洛杉矶的。他从带轮子的行李箱里拉出一大堆会议赠品。一件防风夹克。一个旅行保温杯。一个软绵绵的压力球。他展开四五件正装衬衫，挂在衣柜里。然后他停下来，把所有其他东西推到地板上，瘫坐在窗边的超大扶手椅里。
He is quiet for a minute. Then he says what's on his mind.
他安静了一分钟。然后他说出了他心里的想法。
I've been speaking for so long that it's kind of second nature for me to just get up, say a 10, 15, 30 minute speech, sit down, and it's nothing. It's part of my personality, part of who I am. I don't think. But that's what's tiring about it. I don't know what the hell I'm doing in the world anymore. Not that an 18-year-old is supposed to, but I'm at this pivotal point where, where does this fit in 10 years down the line?
我演讲太久了，以至于站起来讲个10、15、30分钟，然后再坐下，对我来说已经是第二天性了，这没什么。这是我人格的一部分，是我的一部分。我不想思考。但这就是让我疲惫的地方。我不知道在这个世界上我到底在做什么。并不是说一个18岁的人就应该知道，但我现在处于这个关键点，10年后这又意味着什么？
At 18, he's almost out of foster care. And when he leaves the system, his days as a spokeskid are pretty much over. All this will end.
18岁时，他几乎要离开寄养体系了。而当他离开这个系统时，他作为“代言少年”的日子基本上也就结束了。这一切都将结束。
The next day, Anthony visits a local prison with the blue ribbon commission. It's a low, sprawling complex. It's looks a bit like an elementary school surrounded by razor wire. We have to go through a security checkpoint. It takes forever.
第二天，安东尼随蓝带委员会参观了一所监狱。那是一个低矮、蔓延的建筑群。看起来有点像被铁丝网包围的小学。我们必须通过安检。这花了好长时间。
Once we're through, a man approaches Anthony.
通过后，一个男人走近安东尼。
And you are the man of the hour?
你就是那个关键人物？
Yeah.
是的。
OK. I'm the administrative assistant to the warden and public information officer. And you are?
好的。我是监狱长的行政助理和公共信息官。你是？
Anthony Pico.
安东尼·皮科。
Anthony--
安东尼——
Pico.
皮科。
Pico. OK. What's your claim to fame, Mr. Pico?
皮科。好的。你的成名之作是什么，皮科先生？
Born and raised in foster care. I'm a commissioner on the commission that's here.
在寄养体系出生和长大。我是委员会的成员。
You're a success story?
你是一个成功故事？
Sort of. We're yet to see.
算是吧。还有待观察。
Well, you are. I can look in your eyes and tell. You are definitely a success story.
嗯，你是。我可以从你的眼睛里看出来。你绝对是一个成功故事。
Anthony winces. People say stuff like this to him all the time. And he hates it. He doesn't like being called a success story, because he knows there's a big difference between the way people see him and the way his life looks and feels from the inside.
安东尼退缩了。人们总是对他这么说。他很讨厌这样。他不喜欢被称为成功故事，因为他知道人们眼中的他和他在内部感觉到的生活之间有很大的区别。
The fact is, Anthony's gone to six high schools in four years. And he's not close to graduating. Most people who meet Anthony have no idea. The few who do are worried and keep nagging him to finish. If you want to drive Anthony crazy, talk about his potential. The word is like an insult to him. A bunch of times, when we talked, he cut me off mid-sentence. You're not going to say potential, are you? Don't say potential. I know, I know, potential. Please don't say anything about my potential.
事实是，安东尼四年里转学了六次。离毕业还很远。大多数遇到安东尼的人都不知道。少数知道的人很担心，一直唠叨他去完成学业。如果你想把安东尼逼疯，就谈谈他的“潜力”。这个词对他来说就像侮辱一样。很多次，当我们谈话时，他会在半截话时打断我：“你不会要说潜力吧？别说潜力。我知道，我知道，潜力。请不要说任何关于我潜力的话。”
I hang out with Anthony for a few weeks, trying to understand how this kid who seems like he should be doing great isn't doing well at all. Our relationship settles into a routine. I follow him everywhere with a microphone. He feels free to tell me--
我和安东尼在一起待了几周，试图理解这个看起来应该做得很好、实际上却一点都不好的孩子是怎么回事。我们的关系进入了一个日常规律。我带着麦克风跟着他到处跑。他觉得可以自由地告诉我——
I'm totally uninterested in  your questions right now.
我对你现在的问题完全没兴趣。
He gets a kick out of needling me.
他喜欢戏弄我。
Let's get a nice sound of my back cracking.
让我们录一下我后背咯吱响的好声音。
[BACK CRACKING]
[后背咯吱响的声音]
God, that still makes me shudder. And he calls me late at night to talk about girls. He is always up late. Sometimes that means grown-ups having to drag him out of bed in the morning, like at a blue ribbon commission meeting that was supposed to start at 8:30 AM.
天哪，那还是让我不寒而栗。他深夜给我打电话谈论女孩子。他总是睡得很晚。有时这意味着成年人不得不早上把他从床上拖起来，比如在蓝带委员会会议上，原本应该早上8点半开始。
It's Christy from downstairs. I was told to come get you, make sure you're awake.
是楼下的克里斯蒂。有人让我来找你，确保你醒了。
This sort of thing can frustrate the adults who depend on him as a speaker. Despite really good intentions, some of them want it both ways. They want Anthony to speak for kids, but they don't want him to act like one.
这类事情会让那些依赖他作为发言人的成年人感到沮丧。尽管他们初衷很好，但有些人想要两头占。他们想让安东尼为孩子代言，但不想让他表现得像个孩子。
The more time I spend with Anthony, though, the harder it is to see anything but a kid.
不过，我跟安东尼待的时间越长，就越难把他看作别的，除了一个孩子。
I kind of think I should put my retainers in, because my teeth are starting to shift way too much.
我觉得我应该戴上保持器，因为我的牙齿开始移位太多了。
For the last couple years, Anthony's been living on his own in a group home for foster youth near a highway overpass in San Francisco.
过去几年，安东尼一直独自住在旧金山高速公路立交桥附近的一个寄养青少年集体宿舍里。
Here's our living room. That's my roommate's uneaten food. I mean, isn't it lovely? There's oil all over the stove, a pan with a bunch of oil, a pot with potatoes. Yeah, it's just really dirty.
这是我们的客厅。那是室友没吃完的食物。我的意思是，这不可爱吗？炉子上全是油，平底锅里有油，锅里有土豆。是的，它真的很脏。
The dirt is not what gets me. What does is this. The place is crushingly lonely. The neighborhood outside is dead. Anthony's roommates are strangers. Every couple months, someone moves in and someone else moves out. Some are OK. Some pick fights. For the most part, everyone holes up in their locked bedrooms and avoids each other.
脏并不是最让我受不了的。真正让我受不了的是这个。这个地方极其孤独。外面的社区像死了一样。安东尼的室友都是陌生人。每隔几个月，有人搬进来，有人搬出去。有些还好。有些会挑起争端。大部分时间，每个人都躲在锁着的卧室里，避免交集。
Anthony spends his time online, checking email, MySpace, Facebook. When he gets curious who else is home, he flips off the hallway light and looks for a glow under each bedroom door. I start to understand why he travels so much.
安东尼上网打发时间，查看电子邮件、MySpace、Facebook。当他好奇家里还有谁时，他会关掉走廊的灯，寻找每个卧室门下的微光。我开始明白为什么他总是到处旅行。
Texas, Atlanta, Washington state. And that's outside of California. Inside California, all the way up to Arcata, Humboldt, a lot in southern California, Monterey--
德克萨斯、亚特兰大、华盛顿州。那还是加州以外。在加州内部，一直到阿卡塔、洪堡，南加州很多地方，蒙特雷——
Most of the time, there is no adult at the group home. None. There's someone there during business hours. But when the kids come home from school or work they're alone. Nobody for advice or protection. Nobody to crack the whip.
大多数时候，集体宿舍里没有成年人。一个都没有。营业时间内有人在。但孩子们放学或下班回家后，他们是独处的。没有人提供建议或保护。没有人来督促。
Public speaking gave Anthony access to caring adults. He's lucky, kind of. When he's anxious, or facing a big decision, he makes the rounds, asks all the adults he knows what he should do. But the problem is they never agree. And they can't make him do anything. Add them all up and they don't equal even one stable parent.
公开演讲给了安东尼接触关心成年人的机会。他算幸运的，某种程度上。当他焦虑或面临重大决定时，他会到处跑，问他认识的所有成年人他该怎么办。但问题是他们从不同意。而且他们没法强迫他做什么。把他们所有人的影响加起来，都不抵一个稳定的父母。
Back at the hotel, I had watched Anthony put on his tie, and asked who taught him. No one, he said. He stood in front of a mirror one day, knotting and unknotting, until he figured it out. He doesn't have a driver's license. He doesn't really know what it takes to get one. And he doesn't want to go to the DMV alone.
在酒店，我曾看着安东尼打领带，问是谁教他的。他说没人。有一天他站在镜子前，打结、拆开，直到他弄明白了。他没有驾照。他并不真正知道获得驾照需要什么。而且他不想独自去车管所。
I'm driving Anthony to school. Finally, I'm going to see what happens that keeps Anthony from living up to his-- sorry, Anthony. No other word for this-- potential. I could tell as soon as I had picked him up it was going to be a bad day.
我开车送安东尼去学校。终于，我将看到是什么事情阻止安东尼发挥他的——抱歉，安东尼。没有别的词了——潜力。我一接他我就能看出来，这会是糟糕的一天。
So describe to me what's around us.
所以描述一下我们周围有什么。
You've got the narrator position. You [BLEEP] narrate it.
你担任叙述者的职位。你[脏话]叙述它。
Fair enough. Here's the situation. Anthony should be off to a university in the fall. He's fallen a full year behind though. So he enrolled in a couple summer classes at City College to try and catch up. Today is his first day of class. But it isn't the first day of class. That was a week ago. He skipped week one of just a six-week session so he could make his speaking gigs in southern California.
有道理。情况是这样的：安东尼秋季应该去上大学了。但他已经落后了整整一年。所以他报名参加了城市学院的几门暑期课程，试图补上。今天是第一节课。但这并不是第一节课。那是一周前的事了。他为了去南加州参加演讲活动，翘掉了六周课程的第一周。
I'm relieved he's finally here. Anthony's a little dismayed about this, but I've become one more adult in his life, all wound up about his high school diploma.
他终于到了，我松了口气。安东尼对此有点沮丧，但我已经成了他生活中又一个对他高中毕业证书焦虑不安的成年人。
So tell me what class--
所以告诉我什么课程——
I'm going to today?
我今天要去？
What class we're going to hear today.
我们要去听什么课程？
Learn 50. It's wonderful. It's for retards.
学习50。太棒了。那是给“弱智”上的。
Wait, what? So what do you learn in Learn 50?
等等，什么？所以你在“学习50”里学什么？
Study skills. Stuff like that.
学习技能。诸如此类的东西。
Do you think it's a good idea to take it?
你觉得上这门课是好主意吗？
For me, yes, because I don't have study skills. I have procrastination skills and [BLEEP] skills. But I don't have study skills. Turn right up here.
对我来说，是，因为我没有学习技能。我有拖延技能和[脏话]技能。但我没有学习技能。在那边右转。
He had to skip orientation too. So he's not sure where the classroom is. We start wandering around campus. We go to one office then another. We cross the entire campus twice. Finally, someone points him to a building.
他也翘掉了迎新会。所以他不确定教室在哪里。我们开始在校园里晃悠。去了一个办公室又去另一个。我们把整个校园穿过了两次。最后，有人指给他一栋楼。
Let's hope it's down this way. Hi.
希望是在这边。嗨。
Who you looking for?
你在找谁？
I'm supposed to go to the Guardian Scholars Program, I might have gotten this wrong.
我应该去“守护者学者计划”，我可能搞错了。
Yeah.
是的。
I just wrote down 233.
我只是写下了233。
No. Wrong room. Guardian scholars? I'm not sure where you go.
不。房间错了。守护者学者？我不确定你应该去哪儿。
OK. Thank you. Well, I feel like a dumb ass.
好的。谢谢。好吧，我觉得自己像个傻瓜。
The longer we look, the more anxious he gets. And embarrassed. He pokes his head into another classroom.
我们找的时间越长，他就越焦虑。而且尴尬。他探头进另一间教室。
I may be in the wrong room.
我可能进错房间了。
Yeah.
是的。
Sorry. OK. [BLEEP] I give up.
抱歉。好吧。[脏话]我放弃了。
We go outside, stand in a small courtyard, silent for a moment. I don't know what to do. I wonder if I should keep my mouth shut, see what he decides to do on his own. But I can't help it. I try to convince him to go back inside, ask someone else, make a phone call, anything.
我们走到外面，站在一个小院子里，沉默了片刻。我不知道该怎么办。我想知道是否应该闭嘴，看看他自己决定做什么。但我忍不住。我试图说服他回去，再问问别人，打个电话，什么都好。
So where could you find out the class number? Is there like a number at the college you could call?
所以你在哪里可以查到班级编号？学校有没有什么号码你可以打？
[BLEEP] that. I'm not going to even bother. I give up.
[脏话]那个。我根本不想费心。我放弃了。
Well, you've still got, five minutes. We can find-- we're right there. Five minutes late is better than not there at all.
好吧，你还有五分钟。我们可以找到——我们就在那儿。迟到五分钟总比不去强。
Not there at all is what I'd prefer, though.
不过，我不去反而是我更想要的。
I don't get anywhere. So we walk to the car and get in.
我哪儿也去不了。所以我们走到车里坐下。
Let me ask you something. And I don't want this question to sound disrespectful at all. It's just--
让我问你一件事。我不想让这个问题听起来不尊重。只是——
Do I even care about education anymore?
我还会关心教育吗？
Well, you can answer. That wasn't exactly what I was going to ask. But maybe that's a good one to answer.
嗯，你可以回答。那正是我要问的。但也许这确实是个好问题。
Not really. What were you going to ask?
并不关心。你要问什么？
Why not, though?
为什么不关心呢？
No. What were you going to ask?
不。你要问什么？
I was going to ask if today was something you wanted to do if you would have found the room?
我是想问，如果你找到了教室，今天是不是你真正想做的事？
Yeah.
是的。
But do you think, like-- I know you missed last week. And I know you're stressed about education and stuff. Are you sort of digging a hole here?
但你认为，就像——我知道你错过了上周。我知道你对教育之类的事感到压力。你是在这儿挖坑吗？
Well, that's because this is a [BLEEP] class.
好吧，那是因为这是一门[脏话]课程。
But it is a class. I mean, it's credits. It gets you closer to graduation.
但它毕竟是门课。我的意思是，有学分。让你离毕业更近一点。
I don't care if it's-- I want to be able to learn something when I go to class. I don't want it to be a filler class. I hate [BLEEP] filler classes.
我不在乎它是否——我想去上课时能学点东西。我不想那是那种凑数的课。我讨厌[脏话]凑数的课。
This is the flip side of everything public speaking has given him. At some point, it turned into maybe the biggest obstacle keeping him from graduating. He's made the same choice-- in one form or another-- over and over again. He's put public speaking first and school last.
这是公开演讲给他带来的另一面。在某种程度上，这可能成了阻止他毕业的最大障碍。他一遍又一遍地做出了同样的选择——以某种形式。他把公开演讲放在第一位，把学业放在最后。
Speaking, he gets his own hotel room. He gets to spend time with people who appreciate him. He gets to feel mastery over something. He gets to be a star. Going to school, he gets math homework and the feeling of being a screw up. It can't compete.
演讲，他有自己的酒店房间。他可以花时间跟欣赏他的人在一起。他能感受到对某事的掌控。他能成为明星。上学，他得到数学作业和自己是个废柴的感觉。它根本没法比。
Do you think you'll go to college?
你觉得你会上大学吗？
I don't think I'm college material.
我不觉得我是读大学的料。
Do you think you'll graduate from high school?
你觉得你会高中毕业吗？
No. All signs point to no. I'm not, apparently, willing to change anything to make myself graduate. And thus far, I've failed at every turn. Education-- no matter how important in the back of my head-- it has not been a priority. And I don't know why.
不会。所有迹象都显示不会。显然，我不愿意改变任何事情让自己毕业。到目前为止，我处处失败。教育——无论我在内心深处认为它有多重要——它一直不是优先事项。而且我不知道为什么。
It's not clear to anyone whether Anthony will make it or not. Not to me, not to him. And if he can't make it-- with all his talent and connections, an actual spokesman for foster kids-- you have to wonder, who can?
没人清楚安东尼到底能不能成。我也没把握，他自己也没有。如果他不能成——拥有他所有的天赋和人脉，一个真正的寄养青少年发言人——你不得不怀疑，还有谁能？
Anthony is the kind of kid you can find at any high school. That super smart one, who has so much messy, distracting stuff going on outside school that he can't keep it in the background. Anthony's problems are just bigger. And he has nothing like a family to help him through, not even a dysfunctional family. But now that he's 18, he doesn't have much time left to fix things and graduate.
安东尼是在任何高中都能找到的那种孩子。超级聪明，但在学校外面有很多混乱、分心的事情，让他没法专注于学业。安东尼的问题只是更大。而且他没有像样的家庭来帮他度过难关，连一个功能失调的家庭都没有。但现在他18岁了，他没剩下多少时间来解决问题并毕业了。
The fact is, foster kids who don't have a diploma when they leave the system almost never get one. Anthony knows he's contributing to his own problems, probably more than anyone else at this point. He also knows that the older he gets, the more he'll be able to mess up his life in a lasting way. He's just not sure he knows how to stop. It's a lot harder than talking about it.
事实是，离开系统时没有毕业证书的寄养儿童几乎永远拿不到证书。安东尼知道他在为自己的问题推波助澜，可能比现在的任何人都要多。他也知道他年龄越大，就越能以持久的方式搞砸生活。他只是不确定自己知道如何停止。这比谈论它要难多了。
Douglas McGray, he is a fellow at the New America Foundation. In the year since we first broadcast this story, a lot has changed for Anthony. He met a California legislator. And she took a chance on him, hired him onto her staff, answering phones, helping out. Anthony moved out of the group home, got an apartment, got his GED, and is currently enrolled in community college.
道格拉斯·麦格雷，他是新美国基金会的研究员。自我们首次播出这个故事以来的一年里，安东尼发生了很大变化。他遇到了一位加州立法者。她给了他一个机会，雇佣他做她的员工，接听电话，帮忙工作。安东尼搬出了集体宿舍，租了公寓，拿到了普通教育发展证书（GED），目前正就读于社区大学。
[MUSIC - "BAD MOUTH" BY FUGAZI]
[音乐 - 富加齐乐队的“BAD MOUTH”]
Act Three, Impeachment Day. Well you can't do a spokesman show without hearing from a presidential spokesman. And there is an unusually candid recording of Joe Lockhart, who did that job for President Bill Clinton from 1998 to 2000. Long after Lockhart was out of the White House, he agreed to go on stage as part of The Moth, which is this group that does these great storytelling evenings.
第三幕，弹劾日。好吧，不听听总统发言人，你就没法做一场关于发言人的节目。这里有一段极其坦率的乔·洛克哈特录音，他在1998年至2000年间为比尔·克林顿总统担任该职务。在洛克哈特离开白宫很久之后，他同意作为“飞蛾”（The Moth）节目的一部分登台，这是一个举办出色讲故事晚会的团体。
Lockhart went on stage and talked about his early days on the job as White House spokesman.
洛克哈特登台讲述了他担任白宫发言人早期的日子。
Just after I started, we went on a trip. We went off to Russia. We were going to Ireland, doing big foreign policy stuff. Trip was going pretty. The last night in Moscow, I was coming into the hotel. And I ran into a friend of mine, an old friend of mine, the godfather to my daughter, I hadn't seen in a couple years. He said, come on, we've got to go out. We've got to go out. And he convinced me, you know, we were going to go see the real Moscow. And we went to-- I'll never forget-- a place called The Hungry Duck.
刚开始后不久，我们去了一次出访。去了俄罗斯。我们当时要去爱尔兰，处理重大的外交政策事务。旅行进行得不错。在莫斯科的最后一晚，我回到酒店。碰到了一个老朋友，我女儿的教父，我几年没见他了。他说：“来吧，我们得出去。我们得出去。”他劝我说，你知道，我们要去看看真实的莫斯科。我们去了——我永远不会忘记——一个叫“饥饿鸭”的地方。
And they were doing things there that I couldn't take my eyes off, so I had to stay till 5:00 in the morning, which was OK because we weren't leaving till 6:00.
他们在那里做了一些我无法移开视线的事情，所以我不得不呆到凌晨5点，这也还行，因为我们直到6点才走。
So I got back to my hotel and made one mistake, which was to sit down on the bed. And obviously, I fell asleep. And I'm telling you, you don't know anxiety until you've woken up as the White House press secretary on your first foreign trip at 6:15 in Moscow without a passport, knowing you've missed Air Force One.
所以我回到酒店，犯了一个错误，那就是坐在床上。很显然，我睡着了。我告诉你们，如果你在莫斯科早晨6点15分作为白宫新闻秘书在第一次海外旅行中醒来，没有护照，知道自己错过了空军一号，你就不知道什么是焦虑。
Now the only good thing that I could think of--
现在我能想到的唯一好事——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The only good thing I think of was the day couldn't get worse. When I finally caught up with the traveling party, I was immediately surrounded by reporters who said, how do you feel about being the first White House press secretary to ever miss Air Force One on a foreign trip? And a strange phrase just caught in my head. And I couldn't lose it.
我能想到唯一的好事是那天不会更糟了。当我终于赶上旅行团时，我立即被记者包围了，他们问：“作为历史上第一个在海外旅行中错过空军一号的白宫新闻秘书，你感觉如何？”一个奇怪的短语浮现在我脑海里。我怎么也忘不掉。
About a week earlier, the president had been at a prayer breakfast talking about his affair with Monica Lewinsky. And he said, you know, I'm really sorry for what I did. And I'm working very hard to make up for it, particularly to those I've hurt the most. So when I got the question of how do you feel, I said, I'm really sorry for what I've done wrong. And I'm working hard to fix it, particularly those who I've hurt the most.
大约一周前，总统曾在祈祷早餐会上谈论他与莫妮卡·莱温斯基的婚外情。他说：“你知道，对于我所做的事情，我真的感到抱歉。我正在努力弥补，特别是对我伤害最深的人。”所以当被问到感觉如何时，我说：“对于我所做错的事，我真的感到抱歉。我正在努力解决，特别是对我伤害最深的人。”
Now mocking the president of the United States when you make a mistake isn't always the best idea. But it came in my head, and I said it. So anyway, the day went on. And we finally had a little break where the president had some private meetings. And I went to the back of the Irish Ambassador's residence to go to sleep. And I hadn't been asleep for more than five minutes. And I was actually pretty hungover, which was why I needed the sleep. And the president's personal aide came back and said, the president's in a meeting right now. And he wants you to come into it.
现在，当你犯错时嘲讽美国总统并不总是个好主意。但它出现在我脑海里，我就说了出来。总之，那一天还在继续。我们终于有了一点休息时间，总统进行了一些私人会议。我去了爱尔兰大使官邸的后面睡觉。我睡着不到五分钟。而且我其实宿醉得很厉害，这就是我为什么需要睡觉的原因。总统的私人助理走回来，说：“总统现在正在开会。他想让你过去。”
Now, I'm not the smartest guy in the world. But this had practical joke written all over it. And I said, get lost. About three minutes later, he came in and said, hey, the president's in. He's in with the band U2, with Bono, and they want to talk to you.
现在，我不是世界上最聪明的人。但这听起来完全像个恶作剧。我说：“滚开。”大约三分钟后，他走进来，说：“嘿，总统在里面。他和乐队U2在一起，和波诺在一起，他们想跟你谈谈。”
I said, well, if the president wants to see me, he can walk his presidential ass right back to this room and ask me himself. Well, about 60 seconds later, the presidential ass showed up and said, what is your problem? These guys want to meet you.
我说：“好吧，如果总统想见我，他可以迈着他总统的屁股走回这个房间，亲自问我。”好吧，大约60秒后，那总统的屁股出现了，说：“你有什么问题？这些人想见你。”
So I walked into the meeting. And this guy, this rock star, Bono comes up and gives me this big hug and says, I really want to meet you. And I said, well, that's great Mr. Bono, but why? And he said, anyone who can handle world affairs-- you know, Monica Lewinsky and all that-- and still has time to stay out all night drinking is my kind of guy.
所以我走进了会议室。这个家伙，摇滚明星波诺走过来给了我一个大大的拥抱，说：“我真的很想见你。”我说：“好吧，那很好，波诺先生，但为什么？”他说：“任何能处理世界事务——你知道，莫妮卡·莱温斯基等等——还有时间整晚熬夜喝酒的人，就是我喜欢的类型。”
When he was on stage at The Moth, Joe Lockhart also talked about what it was like to be press secretary the day that Congress voted to impeach the president, December 19, 1998. He had, he said, three things to deal with that day. The impeachment vote, of course. Also the same day, Bob Livingston, the speaker of the House, declared that he'd had an affair and he was going to resign. And so the White House had to beat back the notion that President Clinton should also resign because of Monica Lewinsky. That was just the early afternoon.
当他在“飞蛾”舞台上时，乔·洛克哈特还谈到了国会投票弹劾总统的那天，1998年12月19日，当新闻秘书是什么感觉。他说，那天他有三件事要处理。当然是弹劾投票。同一天，众议院议长鲍勃·利文斯顿宣布他有婚外情并将辞职。所以白宫不得不抵御“克林顿总统也应该因为莫妮卡·莱温斯基而辞职”的观点。那只是下午早些时候。
Also that day, the Defense Department had bombed Iraq with cruise missiles, because Iraq was not complying with the UN weapons inspections. And Joe Lockhart had to convince the press-- and the country-- that the attacks on Iraq were not a kind of Wag the Dog distraction.
那天，国防部还用巡航导弹轰炸了伊拉克，因为伊拉克不遵守联合国的武器核查。乔·洛克哈特不得不说服媒体——和全国——对伊拉克的攻击不是一种“摇摆狗”（Wag the Dog，指通过战争转移公众注意力）的分心之计。
I then had what we call in the business a communications challenge, because we had two things we had to do in the same time space. And we tried to figure out what to do. We had 150 members of Congress down to stand with the president-- Democrats-- and say, this impeachment was all partisan, it's all politics. And then we had to talk about the war.
我当时在那个行业里有一个所谓的“沟通挑战”，因为我们必须在同一时间空间做两件事。我们试着弄清楚该做什么。有150名国会议员站在总统身边——民主党人——并说，这次弹劾完全是党派偏见，全是政治。然后我们不得不谈论战争。
And I thought, you know what? Sometimes the best thing to do is not worry very much about it, just go out and do it. So out on the south lawn we had the Democrats, very simple message. Partisans, this is politics, Republicans suck. It all went well.
我心想，你知道吗？有时最好的做法就是别太担心，走出去做就是了。所以在南草坪上我们有了民主党人，很简单的信息。党派偏见，这是政治，共和党人糟透了。一切进行得很顺利。
Then we went inside-- only 10 minutes apart, the same podium, just a different room, a different set of flags-- and said, there are no Republicans in this country. There are no Democrats. It's just Americans, and we've won the war. And then the president left, leaving me in the room to explain to 50 waiting reporters how the two things fit together.
然后我们进去——仅相隔10分钟，同一个讲台，只是换了一个房间，一套不同的旗帜——并说：“在这个国家没有共和党人。没有民主党人。只有美国人，我们赢得了战争。”然后总统离开了，留下我在房间里，向50名守候的记者解释这两件事是如何结合在一起的。
And I think it was so audacious that we even took the breath away from the press. And they seemed to let us get away with it. And I remember at the end of this long day, walking across the hall about 20 feet to my office, going in. And one of my closest friends in the White House was there, one of the president's top aides. And he saw me come in. And I sat down. And he went over to the little bar in the office, and got two beers, opened them up, sat down, put his feet up.
我觉得那是如此大胆，以至于我们让媒体都屏住了呼吸。他们似乎让我们得逞了。我记得在这一长天的结束时，走过大厅大约20英尺回到办公室，走了进去。我在白宫最亲密的朋友之一在那里，总统的高级助手之一。他看见我进来。我坐下了。他走到办公室里的小吧台，拿了两瓶啤酒，打开，坐下，把脚跷起来。
And I'll never forget what he said to me, which was, you know, except for getting impeached, we had a pretty good day.
我永远不会忘记他对我说了什么，他说：“你知道，除了被弹劾之外，我们度过了相当美好的一天。”
Joe Lockhart. He's now a consultant in corporate and political messaging in Washington DC. Thanks to The Moth, You can listen to all kinds of stories like this at their website, themoth.org.
乔·洛克哈特。他现在是华盛顿特区企业和政治传播的顾问。感谢“飞蛾”节目，你可以在他们的网站themoth.org上收听各种这样的故事。
And of course, those are the musical stylings of the 42nd president of the United States, recorded in Prague on an official foreign trip.
当然，那些是美国第42任总统的音乐风格，录制于布拉格的一次正式出访中。
Our program today was produced by Lisa Pollak and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, John Jeter, Sarah Koenig, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our web site. Production help from Seth Lind and PJ Vogt. Musical help from Jessica Hopper.
我们今天的节目由莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、约翰·杰特（John Jeter）、萨拉·柯尼希（Sarah Koenig）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。阿德里安·马修威茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）负责运营我们的网站。制作协助来自塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）和PJ·沃格特（PJ Vogt）。音乐协助来自杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who, as always, has this bit of narration to end our program.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他一如既往地有这段叙述来结束我们的节目。
You've got the narrator position. You [BLEEP] narrate it.
你担任叙述者的职位。你[脏话]叙述它。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共电台。